elle a 44 ans elle est mère de deux
enfants réalisatrice et interprète pour
la télévision d'état la première chaîne
russe nos caméras ont pu la suivre à sa
sortie du tribunal à moscou où elle est
revenue à la charge encore une fois
contre le gouvernement de la dîmière
petit
c'était ma décision de dénoncer la
guerre mon initiative à moi dit marina
ovtchinnikova qui avant-hier était une
simple employée sans histoire
aujourd'hui on la décrit comme une des
femmes les plus courageuses de russie sa
page facebook est inondé de messages qui
salue sa bravoure celle qu'elle a
manifesté hier soir quand elle a fait
irruption et crier non à la guerre en
direct sur le plateau du gluten nouvelle
le plus écouté au pays on peut lire sur
la fiche qu'elle a brandi ne croyez pas
la propagande on vous ment cinq petites
secondes qui ont fait le tour du monde
alors qu'elle était arrêtée est
d'abord été libéré parce qu'elle a des
enfants mais dit avoir été interrogé
pendant plus de quatorze heures durant
lesquelles personne ne savait où elle
était plusieurs chefs d'état y compris
manuel macron lui ont offert l'asile et
la protection si nécessaire je souhaite
en tout cas que au plus vite nous
puissions avoir toutes toute clarté sur
sa situation personnelle car elle est
vraisemblablement exposés à une peine de
prison qui pourrait aller jusqu'à 15 ans
et ce en vertu de la nouvelle loi qui
rend illégale toute action publique qui
discrédite l'armée russe la loi sur
l'ascenseur est tellement sévère qu'elle
a poussé des dizaines de journalistes
internationaux mais surtout russe
indépendant à l'extérieur du pays qui
sont venus s'installer ici à riga en
lettonie parce que c'est la seule façon
de rapporter les faits sans la crainte
de subir des représailles
katerina abramova travaille pour le
journal indépendant mais 12 ha qui a
installé ses journalistes à riga pour
des raisons de sécurité elle n'en
revient pas du geste posé en dire par sa
consoeur
toutes ces choses que dire de ce
manifeste que marina oasiennes nico va a
publié pour expliquer la honte qu'elle
éprouve d'avoir menti aux russes et de
les avoir réduits à l'état de zombie
avec la propagande ce qui se passe
actuellement en ukraine est un crime
toute la responsabilité de cette
agression repose sur la conscience d'un
seul homme l'a dit mir poutine dit m
elle a aussi invité les hausses à
manifester ce qui lui a valu une amende
de 350 dollars parmi les messages
d'encouragement qu'elle reçu il ya celui
ci du président d'ukraine volodymyr
zelensky
merci aux russes dit-il qui font sortir
la vérité qui lutte contre la
désinformation comme l'a fait cette
femme avec sa pancarte ce qui attend
marina n'est pas encore clair la loi n'a
pas été testée est ce que le
gouvernement russe voudra qu'on l'oubli
ou est ce qu'on fera d'elle un exemple
du prix à payer pour humilier le kremlin
et son armée mais si thammarat intéresse
qu radio-canada harig